yo what's going on guys FaZe rug here
and today
tone it down a little bring it bring it
down okay sorry I thought it was my
YouTube channel
[Music]
yo what's good guys it's FaZe rug and
these are my 10 Essentials
[Music]
[Applause]
a basketball I cannot live without I
hoop at least three times a week in my
free time and you might not think I'm
good at basketball you know I'm really
short five foot six five foot seven on
good days but I can shoot I have beat
flight reacts in a 1v1 score was 13-2 I
don't like to talk about it that much
but I 1v1 him and then I also 1v1 to
Aiden Ross which I did take the L on and
I really need my Redemption on that yeah
if there is anyone out there that wants
to challenge me to a 1v1 let me know
YouTubers rappers creators anyone I'm
all up for it
[Music]
oh next up we got my keyboard and mouse
and this is for my gaming for those who
don't know I started off my whole
YouTube career through gaming I joined
FaZe Clan in 2012 which they're the
biggest gaming organization in the world
so I actually used to use a controller
but I recently switched over to mouse
and keyboard because I don't play Call
of Duty anymore I played cod with a
controller but now I switched over to my
favorite game of all time Counter-Strike
CS go I'm a beast at CS a lot of people
think I don't game anymore because I
don't post it but I mean once a gamer
always a gamer it's always in my blood
so this is called an extra five mic and
it just feels so good for Counter-Strike
in specific it's crazy some people I see
put their keyboard like this and they
like angle their chair in a way and they
play like this but I can't do that I
just put my keyboard like this and with
the op I flick
oh
yeah this is it so I film a lot of
YouTube videos and I post three times a
week and this is the main camera I use a
lot of my supporters actually ask what I
use and they're curious about it so this
is the Sony a7s3 and for the lens that I
use is a 16 to 35 and once I transition
from gaming to vlogging I got a camera
that a lot of people might be familiar
with it's called the Canon g7x if you
want to make a channel and you do want
to upgrade to like one of the best this
is what I use and I personally think the
quality on my videos are A1
[Music]
this next essential is my supporters and
what I have in my hand right here is
actually a book made by one of my
biggest fans his name is Caesar Solis
and it's just so beautiful I look at
this every time I just feel down I feel
like I I stress out a lot sometimes and
and my fans give me Comfort and as you
can see it's like a lot of photos of me
old pictures my entire family right
there there's like some of the the thank
you messages from my fans here's one
from Caesar here's one from astonishing
awadis AKA Cassandra I'm just extremely
grateful for the position I'm in and I
sometimes get emotional thinking about
how many people I Inspire every day and
it literally just means the world to me
every time I meet a fan or see a nice
comment every day so thank you to
everyone out there who supports me it's
just what I dreamed about as a kid and
the fact that it became a reality I
would never let anything change that my
mom wanted me to go to college so I went
to Community College for two weeks and I
was like I can't focus on YouTube and
college at the same time so I asked my
mom if I could take a six month break
and she said yes still to this day from
eight nine years ago I still read almost
all my comments it's unbelievable I know
it's hard to keep up with a lot but I do
try to read comments as much as I can
[Music]
this next essential is my G fuel energy
drink called chug rug we got the
inspiration from fortnite it was back in
2018 when fortnite was extremely big and
I was into it and I was like what could
we make that looks blue and cool like
chug jug from fortnite and I'm like my
name is rug chug rug oh my god I didn't
even mention I'm on the can guys this is
why it's so special to me as well it's
me holding my hoodie like this and
throwing up phase up
[Music]
potential is important to me it is a
speaker I can't live without this my top
artist of all time is Drake and I know
that's kind of basic but I do have a
giant picture of Drake in my house like
not on some like creepy fan stuff like I
just he's inspired me so much and I just
love his music like I feel like he
doesn't miss so Drake is up there I
listen to 21
Travis Scott Lil Uzi Bad Bunny too I
don't really speak Spanish but I just
vibe to his music a lot I've actually
made one song and it's called going live
and I actually made it just for a
YouTube video I was just like hey like
we need a video idea so let's just hit
the studio a lot of YouTubers are making
songs and I didn't take it serious
whatsoever but the song actually did
come out pretty good and it's I think my
most viewed video on my YouTube channel
of 10 years now
[Music]
my next essential is pretty unique this
was a gift by my best friend Noah it's
an essential oil and I personally love
scents I love cologne I love candles I
just love smelling good yo what's good
bro I'm in the middle I'm in the middle
of the GQ shoot right now all cameras on
me they can hear you
um do you remember what like scents are
in this essential oil that you got me
I smell the vanilla
little extracts in there and
um a lot of love that's all I needed to
hear it's made with a lot of love but it
really does smell fire
[Music]
this next essential is my new brand that
I just launched called one up candy
there wasn't that one candy that was
extremely sour to me I know Warheads are
sour I know toxic waste is sour but I
wanted to make something a little bit
more sour so these are the neutralizer
packets which come in handy with this
challenge you take the neutralizer
packet and you pour it in six to eight
ounce of water bottle and what the
neutralizer does is after the challenge
when you have that sour stuff in your
mouth it actually just takes it all away
it's it's like magic I call it magic
potion
so we're gonna shake it up
so you take three gummies and the
objective of the challenge is to try not
to make a face in 30 seconds I guess
here I go again I've done this like 10
times and I have still yet to succeed
oh my God
did I make a face I already I made one
yeah oh my God that hit me right away
sometimes the longest I've lasted was 15
seconds that was five seconds bro
foreign
I got put on to reading books by my
therapist a few years ago I was going
through a little bit of a hard time and
he gave me this book called code to Joy
and it's the four-step solution to
unlocking your natural state of
happiness and he's one of the authors
actually it genuinely just helped my
mental a lot especially when I was going
through a tough time and from then I
wanted to start reading more books so I
got The Four Agreements gifted to me
which is awesome for your mental
strength and this one was gifted to me
by my manager Nick shout out Nick back
there he surprised me with the Mamba
mentality book and although this is
mainly about basketball it's the way he
viewed his opponents the way he played
basketball it honestly still has a very
powerful mental message like the Mamba
mentality anytime I'm stressed or like
if I'm like nervous about something I'm
not gonna lie I was nervous before this
GQ interview I mean you guys have had
some of like the top A-list celebrities
sitting in this chair so I'm very
grateful to be here I just think about
this I think about that like mental
strength that I should have different
things will help different people out
but definitely don't be afraid to reach
out to anyone uh friends family
teachers whoever it is that you can
contact like just don't be afraid use
your voice and let people know how you
feel you're not a burden to anybody
[Music]
my last and final essential that I keep
in my wallet every single day is a
picture of my entire family I am very
close to my family just a little back
story my parents moved from Iraq
um knowing very little English my dad
found a job at a liquor store and he
just grinded grinded grinded and worked
so many hours and he was able to buy his
own liquor store after so many years so
back in 2017 or 2018 I was finally in a
great position to where I could retire
my dad from work and it was like one of
the craziest full circle moments of all
time because my dad took extremely good
care of me and the fact that I was in a
position to take care of him uh it just
felt amazing I I just felt super blessed
but even to this day six years later
after I retired him he still goes to the
store like three four times a week still
Gets behind the counter my parents they
didn't want me to do tube they actually
just wanted me to go to school but I
just had this like feeling I just I knew
what I loved back then in high school
and it was gaming I had a huge passion
for gaming again never left me but I
just continued to grind and I got one of
my first checks was a which was about
like twenty five hundred dollars
and uh my parents just thought it was
fake they thought it wasn't real money
because like it went through PayPal I
got one of my bigger checks and pulled
money out of the bank and gave money to
my parents I'm like guys it's real I'm
not going to jail I'm just making
YouTube videos and I had to sit down and
walk them through like the whole process
who's paying me can I call my mom
because I feel like she would be super
hyped
hi Mom
hey um we're filming right now
she gets like nervous on camera and
stuff but mom you look beautiful I just
wanted to say thank you for the life you
gave me and I just talked about this
family picture that I hold on to every
day
and I just want you to know like your
son is on GQ now and like I appreciate
you for believing in me and just just
giving me the life that I had
[Music]
no I love you Mom thank you like just
know you've done a lot for me
I love you too Mom thank you sorry for
the cocaine prank by the way